Avec 4 millions d'habitants dans
sa grande région, la métropole
contribue aux émissions de gaz à
effet de serre. La plus grande
part, c'est le transport. La
moitié de la pollution provient
de là.
PATRICK BONIN, campagne Climat-
Énergie, Greenpeace Canada
- Densifier les villes, lutter
contre l'étalement urbain, reste
l'une des principales choses
qu'on doit faire. On a encore
beaucoup trop d'étalement qui
fait qu'il y a des
infrastructures qui sont mis en
place, une dépendance à l'auto
solo, des distances de plus en
plus grandes.
- Ce spécialiste des changements
climatiques set du même avis.
KAREL MAYRAND, PPD Fondation du
Grand Montréal
- Le parc automobile augmente 2
fois plus vite, à un taux deux
fois plus rapide que celui de la
population. Alors c'est
insoutenable. On est forcés de
prendre des décisions,
effectivement, qui vont être
impopulaires.
- Dans le plan climat de la
Ville de Montréal, on propose de
réfléchir à une zone où seuls
les véhicules non-polluants
seraient autorisés.
Qui pourrait ressembler à ce
quadrilatère.
VALÉRIE PLANTE
mairesse de Montréal
- Il va falloir que
collectivement aussi on soit
prêts à avancer. Puis ça, ça va
vouloir dire des fois faire des
choix difficiles.
- Pour atteindre les cibles de
la Ville, soit une réduction de
55% des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre d'ici 2030 et la
carboneutralité, zéro émission,
d'ici 2050.
- J'ai l'impression qu'il va
falloir attendre que ça fasse
extrêmement mal pour qu'il se
passe quelque chose.
- Je ne la prends pas beaucoup
ma voiture. Je vais pas
travailler en voiture. Je marche
le plus possible.
- Il y a le virage aux voitures
électriques qui s'en vient
aussi, ça c'est super bien.
- Mais elles ne représentent
pour l'instant qu'environ 2% de
tous les véhicules qui circulent
à Montréal.
- Les meilleurs alliés pour
réduire la pollution? Les
autobus et métros.
- Montréal est une des villes au
Canada et en Amérique du Nord,
qui a le plus haut taux
d'utilisation des transports
collectifs. Ça, vraiment ça nous
démarque.
- Selon la firme Walk Score,
parmi les villes de plus d'un
million de personnes, Montréal
se classe 3e en Amérique du Nord
pour la qualité du transport en
commun. L'autre combat, ce sont
les îlots de chaleur. Les
quartiers les plus pauvres de
la métropole sont aussi les
moins verts. On prévoit planter
500 000 arbres en 10 ans.
Ici Mathieu Prost
Radio Canada, Montréal